Ramesh a 27 year old farmer in India
lives happily with his family with his
wife and two kids every day morning he
goes to his farm works hard grows his
crops comes back tired and exhausted and
evening to have a meal with his family
and on one day when his wife could not
find him back home she took the kids and
went out searching for him she found him
hanging dead on a tree above his farm
Ramesh committed suicide because he
could not repay a $200 loan that he took
from a microfinance Institute I did not
know Ramesh but as I sat in my high-rise
apartment in Abu Dhabi having built a
career in financial services I felt I
had betrayed I had betrayed my
grandfather and generations before him
who were farmers I felt I had betrayed
the community and small village in India
that I come from in 2006 when Nobel
Peace Prize was given to Muhammad Yunus
for microfinance I was excited and happy
because it was considered the ultimate
financial solution that would help the
poor foreign aid organisations wealthy
philanthropists and global corporations
invested millions of dollars into
microfinance even us who had a few
dollars to spare went onto websites like
Kiva and on click of a mouse lend money
to form
in Ecuador microfinance appealed to the
emotions of a lot of people because of
the simple model it would lend tiny
loans to the poor who could invest grow
business generate returns and then climb
out of poverty today ten years after the
Nobel Peace Prize 40 years since
microfinance has started there's little
evidence that microfinance helps the
poor on the contrary there are several
studies that shows it does not a study
done here at Stanford University across
87 villages in Bangladesh found
microfinance to have no impact on the
income of the poor and in certain cases
found it to have a negative impact a
study done at MIT across 52
neighborhoods in Hyderabad in India
found microfinance did not have any
impact on health education or income of
the poor people and finally a study done
at Yale University in Philippines found
no impact on income of the poor due to
microfinance microfinance as it stands
on a shaky foundation due to three main
reasons first it considers every poor
person to be an entrepreneur you give
him capital he could invest and grow a
business which is in fact not true
studies have found that less than 2% of
micro enterprises survive for more than
three years
number two the high interest rates I was
speaking to a CEO of a microfinance firm
recently and one of the first questions
I asked him was what's your interest
rate
obviously did not give me an answer but
he explained how it works and this is
what he said we give a loan of $10 for
two weeks and expect $12 in return if
you do the math like I did that works
out to 20% interest for two weeks if you
compute that on an annual basis it works
to thousands of percentage in interest
thousands of percentage in interest
every poor person has to pay
microfinance justifies the saying it's
to cover the cost of operation it is to
cover the risk of the business forbes
magazine published a list of top 50
microfinance institutes on an average it
found these firms generating 80% return
on capital 80 percent return there are
very few business in the world which
generates 80 percent annually on capital
and finally the abusive collection
practices microfinance claims 95 percent
collection rate but how do they achieve
this Khurshid Allah was a debt collector
for Grameen Bank in Bangladesh he was
asked to retire early because he
questioned their collection practices
they were asked to threaten and abuse
poor borrowers who are not able to repay
poor borrowers were asked to sell their
clothes or even sell their children to
repay the loan microfinance
started off with the best of intentions
but has failed to deliver on the promise
to the poor and as I did my research
even I failed to find a silver bullet
solution for the problems of the poor
problems of the poor are big complain
and challenging today remains wife faces
the challenge of feeding her young
children at least one meal a day
millions of people across the globe face
similar challenges and tough choices
each and every day of their lives and
what they need is not a microfinance
loan that could make their life
difficult what they need is a regular
source of income that could make their
life easier I am in quest for searching
for a solution and I need your help and
support to find the solution I've
launched this website which is I pledged
world.com to source solutions that could
help solve the problems of the poor so
let us take this first step together to
change the lives of the poor people to
change the way organizations interact
with the poor and the dream of a changed
world that would have a better tomorrow
thank you very much
you